اعلنت تونس وليبيا اتفاقهما على ايواء
المهاجرين من دول افريقيا جنوب الصحراء
والعالقين عند الحدود بين البلدين منذ
قرابه شهر وذلك بعد يومين من وفاه 27
طالبه نجوم قرب الحدود الليبيه التونسيه
بسبب الجوع والعطش ان كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا
ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما فحوى
الاتفاق الليبيه تونسي بشان ايواء طالبي
اللجوء وما السياق السياسي والاجتماعي
للاتفاق الاخير في البلدين ثم على اي نحو
يمكن ان ينعكس الاتفاق الليبي التونسي على
موقف دول شمال افريقيا
[موسيقى]
ان اتفاق بين تونس وليبيا هو بطبيعه الحال
بعدها يعني سوء فهم وبعد جدل كبير وبعد
تداول عديد من الاخبار والعديد من
التقارير الصحفيه وبعد تداول كل ما وقع
على الحدود التونسيه الليبيه من صور
وتوثيق وبعد اتهامات مباشره او غير مباشره
بين الطرفين يصل الطرف الليبي والطرف
التونسي ممثلين في وزيري الداخليه للبلدين
الى الاتفاق على
العوده الى النظام القديم وهو تبادل
المعلومات التنسيق المشترك وايضا الحل
المشترك بين البلدين في ايواء اللاجئين
وطالبي اللجوء العالقين على الحدود اعتقد
انه خطوه
بطبيعه الحال تضع جانب معين من من الرفع
من معاناه الانسانيه ولكن هي تبقى خطوه
همم غير كافيه على اعتبار الوضع الانساني
وعلى اعتبار جمله التحديات اين سيقعهم
وكيف سيقع ايواءهم ومن سيتكفل بكل هذه
المساعدات وهذه المعونات ليبيا وتونس
وبجره غير النظاميه الى اوروبا ما جده في
هذا الامر ان حدثت هناك هجره بينيه من من
تونس باتجاه ليبيا لاسباب هجره ام تهجير
ربما تم ذلك من نوع من التهجير وهذا ما
ذكر في بعض
البيانات والتقارير وكذلك في بيان
المفوضيه الساميه تابع الامم المتحده بان
هناك معامله قاسيه وتهجير وطرد من لهؤلاء
اللاجئين اعتقد ان الامر استخدم او وظف من
قبل اوروبا لاحراج البلدين لاسباب تخص كل
بلد على حده في محاوله لجمع البلدين في
هذا الملف والحصول على اتفاق معهما
مجتمعين الملف لن يتوقف ما دام الدول
المنبع ما زالت تشهد اضطرابات وان مشكله
اللاجئين لا تحل الا بحل الازمات
الانسانيه في الدول التي يخرج منها هؤلاء
اللاجئين التقارير كانت قويه ووجدت اذان
صاغيه حتى في الامم المتحده التي اصدرت في
بدايه شهر شهر الحالي كذلك بيانا شديد
اللهجه حول وضعيه وضعيه اللاجئين او
الطالبيه اللجوء بين الحروف الحدود بين
تونس وكذلك ليبيا النقطه الثانيه هي كذلك
العديد من النواب قاموا بضغط كبير على
الحكومات الاوروبيه بعد توقيع الاتفاقيه
ما يسمى اتفاقيه الاستراتيجيه الشامله ما
بين تونس والاتحاد الاوروبي باعتبار انها
لا تراعي العديد من القضايا
الحقوقيه فجاءت الصوره المنقوله حول
العديد من طالب اللجوء من افريقيا جنوب
الصحراء
جاءت يعني بوقع قوي جدا واثارت العديد من
الانتقادات
داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي الذي اعتقد كذلك
يعلم جيدا بان لا قيمه في النهايه
للاتفاقيه الموقعه مع تونس مؤخرا ولا حتى
الاتفاق السابق باعتبار كان هو النموذج مع
ليبيا اذا لم تتفق قبل كل شيء الدولتين
الجارتين تونس وليبيا
اوروبا لم تعد تحتمل هذا التدفق وهناك
ضغوطات ويستغل هذا الملف سياسيا حتى في
اوروبا بالنسبه للمعارضين امام الحكومات
بالتالي يطلب من ربما سنرى ذلك واضحا في
الفتره القادمه من ليبيا وتونس ووضعهما في
اتفاق واحد بالتعامل مع هذا الملف وتحمل
نفقاته وما يترتب عليه من اجراءات قانونيه
وتوطين وادماج في المجتمع مثل ما هو منصوص
عليه وفي المواثيق الدوليه وهذا امر
الحقيقه متعذر ليبيا تفتقر الى الاستقرار
السياسي وتفتقر كذلك الى الاستقرار الامني
هذا تحدي كبير جدا لا تستطيع التعامل مع
هذا الملف بكل حال من الاحوال وتونس كذلك
في تحدي كبير اقتصادي ما منح لها هو بعض
المبالغ البسيطه الحقيقه 150 مليون يورو
ثم 100 مليون اخرى لمعدات لحرس الحدود كل
ذلك غير كافي صحيح يعني مبلغ غير كافي اذا
قارنا ذلك بحجم التحديات الكبيره لقضيه
الهجره غير النظاميه لكنه يعني مبلغا
استطاع اقناع على الاقل السلطات في تونس
من اجل التعاون والدخول في هذه الشراكه
التي تتجاوز قضيه الهجره غير النظاميه الى
خمس محاور منها البيئه منها كذلك الاقتصاد
الى غير ذلك
[موسيقى]
ليس هناك حلول حقيقيه للاعداد الهائله
التي تدفق على تونس سواء كان من الحدود
البريه او العدد الاكبر اثناء عمليه
الانقاذ البحري اليوم مع تحديث الخطه
الاوروبيه ومع كل ما عزم الاتحاد الاوروبي
بقياده ايطاليا العمل في البحر الابيض
المتوسط انه تونس
تتحدث تتحمل لوحدها
اعمل اللي هي
يمكننا من انقاذ وتاتي بمئات اضعاف المرات
من ما تاتيه الحدود البريه وهذا بطبيعه
الحال في ظل غياب تاب لاي رؤيه حقيقيه
خاصه وانه مذكره تفاهم لم ترتقي بعض الى
الاتفاق هناك ضغوط كبيره جدا على تونس
ودائما وابدا احنا كنا ننتقد تلازم
المسارات مسار ان تصل تونس الى الصناديق
المانحه والى البنك الدولي والى التمويلات
الدوليه مقابل امضاءها على هذا الاتفاق
وبالتالي هي اليوم وضعها الاقتصادي
والسياسي يجعلها تحت طائله الضغط الاتحاد
الاوروبي الحكم الليبيه تعرضت لغضوض شديده
خلال فتره يعني منذ توليها يعني اذا رجعنا
الى الحكومه السابقه نتذكر تعرض مركز
اللاجئين الى القصف اثناء الحرب في عام
2019 وعام 2020 والمجتمع الدولي بقى صامت
ولم يتعامل مع هذه رغم انه يمثل من جريمه
من جرائم الحرب على كل حال الحكومه
الليبيه يعني
تعلم
الانقسام السياسي وخروج اماكن كثيره عن
سيطره الحكومه بسبب وجود دائما سلطات
موازيه وسلطات عسكريه خارج سلطه الحكومه
يضاعف او يفاقم من هذا التحدي